une journée de sensibilisation sur le
handicap à verneuil-sur-seine un petit
groupe de personnes s'est réunie sur la
place du marché suite à l'appel de
l'association apf france objectif de
cette mobilisation dénoncé l'accès aux
lieux de soins on voudrait mettre le
doigt sur le chantier qui est devant
nous pour parler d'avenir parce que ce
qui est derrière nous on laisse derrière
nous de parler d'avenir et essayez
d'imaginer ce que sera le monde de
demain en termes d'accès aux soins
cette journée est également l'occasion
pour ces personnes en situation de
handicap de parler de leurs difficultés
au quotidien je ne peux sortir de chez
moi qu'en empruntant la chaussée parce
que beaucoup de bateaux n'existe pas ou
ou entre il ya des passages pour piétons
et de part et d'autre ce sont des
trottoirs il n'y a pas d' abbey soeur
c'est dangereux oui oui oui
selon l'association apf france 9
personnes sur 10 se rencontrent des
difficultés dans leurs déplacements
parmi eux des mères de famille avec
leurs poussettes des enfants encore des
personnes âgées
des chiffres qui ont interpellé les élus
locaux nous mettons à verneuil en place
une commission d'accessibilité pour
associer les associations et puis plus
globalement les personnes qui sont
volontaires afin de travailler sur ces
questions et d'améliorer l'existant et
puis aussi de réfléchir à comment on
peut travailler
l'avenir de nos infrastructures de nos
lieux qui vont être aménagés d'autres
actions de ce type pourraient être
organisées dans les prochains mois